in 1976
a deadly illness erupted in a remote
province of zaire
belgian nuns tending to the sick
described horrific symptoms
followed by agonizing deaths it took tax
tissue around the body
uh basically attacks everything in the
human body except for your bones
doctors from zaire europe and america
traveled to the epicenter to investigate
when responders got there they had no
idea what they were looking at but they
did know
that they were looking at this deadly
new virus
the researchers might not have known
what this new virus was
but they learned how it spread so
quickly
medical supplies were so scarce here
that the belgian nurses had resorted to
reusing hypodermic needles
this virus had an astounding mortality
rate
of nearly 90 percent
in less than two months it claimed some
300 lives
then suddenly the nightmare ended and no
one knew why
they just knew the virus popped out of
nowhere and it disappeared just as
quickly
epidemiologists named it ebola zaire
after the nearby ebola river
and dreaded its return which it did
in just a few relatively contained
outbreaks over the next decade
but the greatest fear was that someday
the virus would emerge in a densely
populated region
which it also did
so back in 1989 in the washington suburb
of reston
all of a sudden a bunch of monkeys at a
warehouse started dying
hazelton laboratories rest in virginia
one of the largest
animal testing companies in the country
a shipment of 100 long-tailed macaques
came in from the philippines
two were dead on arrival
[Music]
the illness quickly spread to dozens of
monkeys
desperate for a diagnosis the company
sent
samples to a high security lab run by
the military
the us army medical research institute
of infectious diseases
or usamrid lieutenant colonel nancy
jacks
examined the tissues what we found then
was really pretty alarming
i was seeing a section of liver
i saw all these very large cells which
are called macrophages
and they were full of material
which is very typical in a filo virus
infection
a filo virus a tiny spaghetti-like
strand
that replicates at lightning speed and
causes devastating diseases
dr jacks was very familiar with them she
worked behind layers of bomb resistant
walls
where the army stored an archive of
frozen killers
marburg ebola sudan
and the most lethal of all ebola zaire
dr jacks used her stash of filo viruses
to compare to the monkey sample
and to her surprise the one that matched
was the virus that struck zaire in 1976
we're thinking well that's not possible
we need to check it again
and they checked it three times and
every time there was no mix-up it was
showing positive for ebola as i hear
i think nancy came to my office
you're not going to believe what just
happened you know it looks like we've
got
ebola virus in these monkeys in virginia
there was a lot of confusion and going
oh wow this is
this is really crazy what are we going
to do we immediately had to kick into
high gear
the army formed the battle plan first
order
euthanized the monkeys to prevent an
epidemic
nancy's husband colonel jerry jacks led
the team
nobody likes killing monkeys but we were
in an emergency situation it was
something that we had to do
to make sure that we didn't have a
significant outbreak within the human
population
they dodged a bullet and they soon
realized
this strain of ebola wasn't harmful to
humans
but they knew it was only a matter of
time before they'd have to face the
unimaginable
the question of course is are you going
to get a mutation that
then makes it more airborne or makes it
more
contagious what we did in a contained
building
was pretty dramatic but imagine if it
was a city
the nightmare scenario for global public
health officials is something that
combines
the transmissibility of something like
the spanish flu which infected
probably about a billion people a
century ago and the mortality of ebola
what keeps me up at night is that we'll
have a disease that's transmitted by
droplets something that is respiratory
borne
that is a virus like influenza likely
influenza
that has both high degree of of uh
transmissibility and high degree of
morbidity and mortality
if something like that spreads around
the world we're just not ready to fight
it
[Music]
you